how's it going rest my name is Brianna
fat
welcome back some more happy with us it
looks like have you stopped going on the
air park rocked it
why would there be a walkthrough of our
dishes awesome hey what are you doing
man don't know but I got a Pogo god damn
yeah what the [ __ ] man uh whatever I'll
just dolphin my way out of here yeah
regular day and happy wheels pike
alright let's go a little faster this is
why I don't really like the Pogo guys so
slow I have a go Pacha backflip are ye
let's go to the toilet why I don't know
alright we're not like so good hey guys
hey guys how you doing how you done you
drinking water you drink it's Friday I
know you made me spell out my I don't
care about spilling all right hey night
I kissed you and your chest and then I
like that's no what happened hey Santa
how you doing buck blog oh I miss okay I
definitely think this is Howie they
wanted that happy Willis cake alright I
don't care keep molesting my chillin
bling all right here we go
another day another happy day and Chuck
why are you running are you going guys
alright let me dip dolphin my way out of
here hey guys got into fish lately Kyle
Kyle you're not responding I get it I
get it
you treat me like I don't excel right
another random brick wall must jump over
oh come on man you can do it I wasn't
even have they checked me what is this
RAC plane show up well what the hell man
you could have killed me die Wow again
oh you don't battle is on now no your
dick will have my dick well what why am
I talking about
alright this is [ __ ] slowest all
right this is jump
let's probably go faster what's this
jean-bernard yeah
he probably would that have it looks
like [ __ ] I bet it looks like you're
responsible of that whoa come on man
this stinks
I mean hot dogs don't get them deck
speed up there we go what are they doing
I gotta jump over this [ __ ] alright fat
lady you will help me ah maybe not
c4 scar skull hey blockage blackish my
ball now my ball now and you have how
many balls zero but I wanted to kill you
by buzz sorry man sorry about your boss
second body third box whoa holy [ __ ] man
what no no no my legs it's actually kind
of cool look at this ladies like my legs
my legs are amazing my arm is still
moving - that's pretty cool
that is pretty awesome I just wanted to
have it Levesque I kiss your leg and
then I come back and cassia and they I
tease here I teach you I teach you I
come closer I can close I went to kiss
my daughter's beauty and then I come
non-skid okay I think I think I can
probably should stay off maps like that
one I just have an idea that it's
probably Warmachine rampage part - OH
daym yeah yeah I'm an old man
all they call me I can all pay for
[ __ ] murder people I guess they can
die anyway
whoa damn that's badass no no no no this
car does not do front flips oh wait it
does her anyway ha ha ha you can't well
I got a [ __ ] log in my car how many
people can say that
hey lag you comin
ah we lost log but we gained a new power
up failing Wow
falling television I can't read leg
we'll just spin on for eternity until I
stop it right there
harpoon no I love that fun but I already
played it what about this try to survive
- I don't really get these but are you
dying by haha [ __ ] look what you're dead
I just want us to be friends
ok well finish this for your dad
[ __ ] me that's right
come on yeah there we go Derrick I'm
gonna do this for your dad come on man
come on I can do it yeah you suck man
are you miss a class right are you
actually then it start of weapon throw
kill kill
throw weapons
illusions and cup game don't know demo
don't move harpoons this is a demo about
this kill and slay that played I add a
play guy telling me kill him hey not in
my deck you can but I need to have a
toilet
you guys have [ __ ] and a pineapple [ __ ]
yeah got a lot of tallest man what's in
conveyor I found that out that i always
rub my beard every time i try to pick am
a bit like run away don't read this and
rap but god damn it they tricked me
alright let's go back hey you came back
hey still moving
yeah yeah yeah you think he's gonna stop
me [ __ ] now come here old man gimme a
kiss wow that is not the type of case I
want is it yeah I plan still alive
[ __ ] beginning yeah - whoa hey I got
an arrow head I don't you dad come near
me Jennifer
here we go whoa [ __ ] that was close hi
ladies sorry about that
you should not you're not gana [ __ ] I
am on the ganda that can stay in this
way Wow
why the fact that I did okay last try
well hey come on man
let me stay here stay here yeah badass
[ __ ] gotta say my son yeah crazy whoa
come on
okay let's just go well late whoops Wow
let's go go what is his head doing in my
bike stop kissing my bike is mine [ __ ]
yeah that's how we roll oh man
giant guns pretty cool reminds me how
that's smart and Freddie Wong oh it's a
huge guns think fastening yeah all right
not even ready come on what what hey man
I would hug whoa no thanks buddy you
[ __ ]
yay hey I want to touch a penis come
here
later [ __ ] what is going on Dutch ah
boy
oh damn I blockage back touch it hey
whoa we both made it okay whoa nevermind
nevermind I out burned can you survive
past no but I can survive slow so I
don't really like those it gets old with
the same stuff and why people do with
the same stuff it's fun when you do new
stuff I'm gonna fight you can do you
don't have to make so much throw
sometime you can make you can make they
see me rollin they hatin patrolling and
trying to catch me ridin dirty tryna
catch me ridin dirty tryna catch me
ridin dirty tryna catch me ridin dirty
this one has like a million I don't know
what exclamation points so anyway fifty
apprehend of happy wheels is like this
it's [ __ ] true actually super epic
impossible no idea what I just talked
about
super mega epic
Oh how did you do that - oh wow
Jack Norris actually can't even do it
well I guess I'm not sucking noise class
enough the sec no epic Hunstanton
oh no oh but doesn't funny cuz the
characters are like becomes a little
weird kind of [ __ ] I don't know but
there are some of them are missing I got
to know how many I play they actually
crash it epic jet 5 what the hell they
see me rollin they hatin but they [ __ ]
you I mean wait okay [ __ ] off [ __ ] off I
just love when he goes in a try ah for
me why aren't you sweet I hate you
Alice Bailey let me take out on this
battle fighting thank it's too far down
thank you very much can t you take care
of this please yes son I have don't grab
the change what [ __ ] yo don't [ __ ] off
that's right daddy
oh we're going there right good don't
grab it that's what you get you little
[ __ ] okay so I'm supposed to go in here
let's go down down here what's up here I
don't think that's no that's definitely
not how you do it they say my role in
being a [ __ ]
alright what's going on it yeah come on
yeah [ __ ] yeah whoa no no it's a doubt
[ __ ] dad I was close enough close enough
in my opinion
what do you bros do you even bother me
to actually finish let me found like
that or that's good enough I don't know
all right I was pretty much ended here
like babies enjoy
say aha chairman activate
Oh
[ __ ] this [ __ ]